[Music]
look stop we're not supposed to be doing
that after 6 p.m who says our HOA it
says so clearly in the ccnrs the
Credence Clearwater Revival
covenants conditions and restrictions
give me a break this is America nobody
can tell an adult what they can do in
their own home uh actually they can
[Music]
thank you
there are so many important factors to
consider when buying a house from
mortgage terms to inspections to school
districts it's understandable that some
things that don't seem too important now
will get neglected only to buy you down
the road one such example is the HOA or
homeowners association a self-governing
board that oversees a community of
homeowners whether in single-family
homes townhouses or condos HOAs are
funded by monthly dues collected from
all members and exist to keep property
values High the main ways they do this
are by offering amenities and enforcing
restrictions amenities offered by HOAs
come in many different flavors a gated
community might have security guards
patrolling at night a subdivision of
tract houses might have a community
swimming pool and a condominium building
needs to keep the elevators working and
the lobby neat and tidy these things all
cost money and the amount of dues
collected will reflect the extravagance
of the amenities a simple HOA that
offers a garbage pickup service and
maintains a playground might only ask
residents for a hundred fifty dollars a
month while a beachfront condo could
easily charge a thousand dollars a month
to operate a spa and fitness center you
can't opt out of paying for these
amenities so before you commit make an
honest assessment of whether you'll
actually use them generally the services
that make everyday life easier like snow
shoveling or garbage pickup are a safer
bet than luxuries like gyms and swimming
pools but restrictions are where HOAs
really Flex their muscles do you live
for Halloween and literally count the
days until you can bedeck your house
with all manner of ghosts and Ghoulies
better read those ccnrs pretty closely
because some HOAs May prohibit holiday
decorations of any kind let alone the
Gory Tableau you've dreamed up maybe
your family has three cars but only a
two-car garage that's okay you can just
park the extra one on the street right
well that depends no age HOA has
jurisdiction over public streets but if
the street is private like say in a
gated community HOA can make rules about
what kinds of vehicles can park there
for how long or even prohibit street
parking entirely they can even dictate
whether you can park your car in your
own driveway let's say you've just
inherited the handmade Farmhouse mailbox
your grandfather made better rethink it
as a backyard birdhouse because your new
HOA loves uniformity Above All Else some
even require your roof shingles to match
your neighbors other common restrictions
include no parties no renters no Flags
no long-term visitors no pets over 25
pounds or no pets period okay but are
these really Ironclad rules or just
guidelines if you bent them a little bit
how much trouble could you really get
into the answer a lot courts in many
states have determined that ccnrs are
legally binding documents unless they
violate public policies depending on the
terms you could be fined sued or have a
lien put on your home HOAs don't play
one in Florida confiscated 80 residents
trash bins and dropped them off at a
recycling center for leaving them in
plain view for too long a man in
California had to pay seventy thousand
dollars of his hoa's legal expenses and
lost his home his crime planting too
many rose bushes in his front yard so if
you think you'll have trouble complying
with any of your hoa's restrictions it's
best to look elsewhere rather than risk
a showdown conversely these restrictions
might just be what you're looking for
like say if you're deathly afraid of
dogs or have trouble sleeping and don't
want to be disturbed by loud neighbors
once you've balanced the amenities with
the restrictions and dues there's one
more aspect of your HOA to consider
assessments sometimes major repairs are
required on shared spaces like if the
community pool needs resurfacing or the
elevators need special maintenance or
the roof of a condo is damaged in a
storm in these cases the HOA may have
the authority to demand that every
member chip in to pay for the Emergency
upkeep which depending on the problem
and the number of members can result in
an unexpected Levy in the hundreds or
even thousands of dollars these surprise
fees are known as assessments and though
they can feel onerous they are not to be
taken lightly take for example the
collapse of the Champlain Tower South
Condo building in Miami in June of 2021
for years before the tragedy the condo
board knew that the building was in dire
need of repair but was reluctant to ask
the residents for the 80 to 200 thousand
dollars in assessments it would cost per
unit part of the problem is that HOA
boards are often made up of volunteer
members who have little experience in
finance or construction and are under
pressure from residents to keep dues as
low as possible according to one study
about one-third of such associations
have less than a third of the savings
they'd need to pay for sudden but
eventual repairs as Jeffrey Ducker a
principal in the audit Department of a
Florida public accounting firm put it if
you're looking to buy a home in an HOA
be sure to ask for a copy of its
financial statements look at what its
liquidity is if it has sufficient
working capital to operate and if it has
set aside reserves for future major
repairs and replacement if it doesn't
have reserves that would be considered a
negative factor despite the cost and the
pitfalls HOAs are actually pretty
popular the community associations
Institute reports that 85 percent of
residents that have an HOA are satisfied
with it additionally researchers at the
University of California at Irvine found
that homes with an HOA sold for four
percent more than those without on
average for many people HOAs can make
their home a better place to to live and
a safer investment as long as you have a
competent board and can abide by the
restrictions you might be one of them so
I can go back to practicing the drums
only between the hours of ten and six or
you could get an electric kit and put on
some headphones which actually sounds
like a good idea to me
and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
for more about the unexpected bumps on
the path to home ownership check out our
video how do you actually buy a house
[Music]